[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh toi ma femme aux paupières le célèbre
bleu
regarde fabuleux des enfants c'est au
nez aux grands yeux prophétique où l'on
voit se baigner les elfes mystérieuse en
paillettes dorées
des lances ils font le tri en fumée de
gitanes des lances ils sont les rameaux
vagues de la mer et pour le vix fermé
par ma bouche sonneurs
et lens il fonde étrillant fumée 18h
au toit ma femme aux pommiers aisne le
cèdre bleu
des baisers on le sucre et tortillas
indienne
les fleurs d'acacia rose de gâteaux de
noël de pâte feuilletée four et d'orties
aux miennes
ma femme au pied de l'une aux empreintes
de fleurs
vérité poignard qui déchire les nus
ma femme mourir mû au semble retenue
ma femme au pied de l'une aux empreintes
de fleurs
toi ma femme au pied dans le c double
aux cris d'oiseaux plaintif dans ton
sommeil d'enfants
aux étreintes jalousant mâchoire de tir
vous êtes un peu jalouse en boîte de
diamants
votre palpitant lecaille ans ambiante et
à la bouche tendue comme un quartier
d'orange
ma femme aux seins secrets aux lèvres
devant l'enjeu au ventre palpitant
lecaille ensanglanté
et je suis là moi je suis là sans rien
dire
donnant les oiseaux dans ma bouche
fermée
et j'ai tant que m'amuser j'ai toute ma
vie
retenant les sois sûr dans ma poche est
fermé
oh
oh toi ma femme aux pompiers de ces
troubles
l'on doit de corail dans mes cheveux de
l'est
hollande doit qui s'attarde aux bouches
des fontaines
toi ma femme en paupières le cèdre bleu
je t'ai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]